comme les bars restaurants et cafés les
campings sont fermés depuis le 17 mars
fermées elles jusqu'à nouvel ordre alors
que les hôtels reprennent leurs
activités
une différence de traitement qui pose
question les campings pourrait rouvrir
le 2 juin si l'épidémie continue de
reculer
confirmation attendue la semaine
prochaine reportage en provence alpe
côte d'azur et d'isabelle ferrière avec
rania berrada thierry col on gère le
camping international de hyères en
provence alpes côte d'azur depuis le 17
mars
son établissement reste désespérément
fermée située sur la presqu'île de giens
ce camping 4 étoiles ouvert à l'année
emploie 20 salariés en temps normal dix
sept d'entre eux sont aujourd'hui au
chômage partiel pour payer ses charges
thierry coulomb a dû contracter un pg e
un prêt garanti par l'état d'un montant
de 700 mille euros une dette qui sera
difficile à rembourser
par exemple pour une petite exploitation
une entreprise comme moi on est à 20 % 2
du chiffre d'affaires qui a été perdu
voilà et ça c'est quelque chose qui va
être difficile à rattraper
alors bon on a fait on a fait
fonctionner les crédits de trésorerie
avec les banques mais ça veut dire c'est
de l'endettement pure simple thierry
coune on ne sait toujours pas quand il
pourra rouvrir un arrêté publié ce jeudi
oblige les campings à rester fermés
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
contrairement aux hôtels qui peuvent eux
reprendre leurs activités
une différence de traitement que ne
s'explique pas le président de la
fédération régionale d'hôtellerie de
plein air nous avons des hébergements
complètement individualisé chez des
chalets avec tout le confort dedans
individuels comme pour être un
appartement ou même une maison de une
résidence secondaire
donc effectivement on ne comprend pas
très bien pourquoi nous permet pas de
rêver les établissements même s'il
fallait laisser fermer des piscines ou
d'autres services a effectivement lieu
au moins d'hébergement république
conserver de même l'accueil des camping
cars par exemple on pouvait très bien
c'est individualisé j'avais leur service
intérieur de sanitaires y avait pas de
problème pour les accueillir la région
paca attire 6 millions de touristes
étrangers chaque année depuis le début
de la pandémie
ces pertes dépassent les 100
milliards d'euros c'est la région
française la plus touchée par la crise
du secteur